Anthony benedetto known to the world as
Tony Bennett launched his career in his
native New York
his first number one song in 1951
because of you
it had to be you Bennett called his
style intimate singing in the tradition
of popular American crooners I'm all for
you body and soul much younger artists
he later paired with like Amy Winehouse
and Lady Gaga marveled at Bennett's
relaxed approach to recording
[Music]
it's something I said great we got it
and they say you're kidding
I said no that that's it you know the
falling leaves Bennett's style fell out
of favor when rock music caught on but
he staged a comeback in the 1980s and
90s with albums that attracted younger
audiences
I left
my heart
foreign
Francisco
through the decades the tomb that became
his most famous boosted Bennett's Global
appeal
my signature song is I Left My Heart in
San Francisco and everybody says don't
you ever get tired of singing that
because I do it all over the world I get
commissioned to sing it it's made me a
world citizen I happen to love the song
the winner of 20 Grammys including a
Lifetime Achievement Award in 2001
Bennett recorded music until he was
diagnosed with Alzheimer's in 2015.
the city of San Francisco honored him
with a statue for his 90th birthday
[Music]
a thank you for the Legacy he leaves to
the Great American Songbook
foreign